hablemos de lo que nunca cambiará en la narración.
Shonda Rhimes: Lo que nunca cambiará.
Obviamente, creo que las buenas historias nunca cambiarán,
la necesidad de las personas de juntarse e intercambiar historias
y hablar de las cosas trascendentales,
la idea de que todos sentimos una imperiosa necesidad de conocer historias,
de contarlas, de compartirlas...
de reunirnos en torno a una fogata
para hablar de las cosas que nos indican
que no estamos solos en el mundo.
Para mí, esas cosas nunca cambiarán.
La esencia de la narración nunca cambiará.
CS: Bien. Cuando me preparaba para esta conversación,
contacté a Susan Lyne,
que estaba a cargo de ABC Entertainment
cuando trabajabas en "Anatomía de Grey".
SR: Sí.
CS: Y ella me dijo que tenía un recuerdo imborrable
de tu proceso de selección,
en el que, sin discutirlo con ninguno de los ejecutivos,
invitaste a gente a venir a leer tus guiones,
y en ellos había todo tipo de personas,
no consultaste con nadie en ninguna forma,
y eso fue totalmente sorprendente.
Ella me dijo que además de volver a enseñar algo nuevo a los ejecutivos,
y a ti, ella siente,
y creo que es... concuerdo,
es cambiar las expectativas de la audiencia televisiva de EE.UU.
¿De qué otra cosa la audiencia no se ha dado cuenta que necesita?
SR: ¿De qué más no se ha dado cuenta aún?
Bien, bueno... No creo que hayamos llegado a ese punto aún.
Es decir, todavía estamos en un punto
muy, muy lejano de lo que el mundo es en realidad.
No es que trajera a un montón de actores
que lucieran muy diferentes unos de otros
solo porque tratara de demostrar algo,
y tampoco trataba de hacer algo especial.
Nunca se me ocurrió que fuera algo nuevo, diferente o extraño.
Solo traje a los actores porque pensé que eran interesantes
y para mí, el que fuera tan sorprendente para todos...
No lo supe sino después de un tiempo.
Solo pensé: estos son los actores que quiero ver en estos papeles.
Quiero ver cómo se ven leyéndolos.
Veremos qué pasa.
Así que, lo interesante
es que si miras el mundo desde otro lente,
cuando no eres la persona que normalmente está a cargo de las cosas,
simplemente sale de otra manera.
CS: Bien. Ahora maniobras esta gran máquina,
como un titán -- como sabrán, dio una charla el año pasado --
ella es un titán.
¿Qué crees que va a pasar con el tiempo?
Hay mucho dinero de por medio invertido en estos programas.
Si bien las herramientas para crear historias se han democratizado,
aún existe esta gran distribución:
gente que alquila cadenas y audiencias a anunciantes
y lo echan a andar.
¿Cómo cambiará el modelo de negocio ahora que cualquiera puede ser narrador?
SR: Creo que siempre está cambiando.
Es decir, es sorprendente lo rápido que está cambiando.
Y siento -- el temor es palpable,
y lo digo sin mala intención --
Creo que es emocionante.
La idea de que haya algo como un igualador,
el que cualquiera pueda hacer algo, es maravilloso.
Creo que es aterradora la idea de que no se puede encontrar un buen empleo.
Hay muy empleo.
Creo que actualmente en la TV hay 417 series dramáticas
en cualquier momento, en cualquier lugar,
pero no puedes encontrarlas.
No puedes encontrar las buenas.
También hay cosas malas porque cualquiera puede hacer algo.
Es como si todos hicieran una pintura.
Como saben, no existen tantos buenos pintores.
Pero encontrar buenas historias, buenos programas,
es cada vez más difícil.
Porque si solo hay un programita de cable por aquí
y otro por allí y por allá,
encontrar dónde están se vuelve más difícil.
Creo que descubrir las joyas
y averiguar quién hizo el gran webisodio, y quién hizo esto otro,
es... pienso en los pobres críticos
que pasan 24 horas al día
atrapados en sus casas viendo de todo.
No es un trabajo fácil hoy en día.
Y los motores de distribución están volviéndose más y más vastos,
pero encontrar buena programación para toda la audiencia
se hace más difícil.
Y a diferencia de las noticias,
donde todo se reduce a solo quién eres,
la TV parece estarse volviendo...
y por TV me refiero a todo lo que se puede ver, programas de TV...
todo parece más y más extenso.
Así que cualquiera crea historias,
y los genios a veces están escondidos.
Pero va a ser más difícil encontrar,
y en algún punto va a colapsar.
La gente habla de la cima de la TV.
No sé cuándo vaya a ocurrir.
Creo que en algún punto va a colapsar un poco
y entonces nos uniremos.
No sé si vaya a ser una cadena de TV.
No sé si ese modelo sea sostenible.
CS: ¿Qué hay del modelo
en el que Amazon y Netflix están invirtiendo tanto dinero ahora?
SR: Es cierto.
Creo que es un modelo interesante.
Creo que hay algo de emocionante en ello.
Para los creadores de contenido, creo que hay algo de emocionante.
Para el mundo real, creo que hay algo emocionante en ello.
El que haya programas ahora
en múltiples idiomas con personajes de todo el mundo
que son interesantes y que conectan con todos al mismo tiempo
es emocionante.
Es decir, creo que el sentido internacional que la TV asume ahora,
tiene sentido para mí, que la programación pueda asumir el reto.
La TV ha sido creada para la audiencia de EE.UU.
Realizamos estos programas
y luego los arrojan al mundo
y esperamos lo mejor,
en lugar de pensar que realmente eso no representa a EE.UU.
Es decir, nos amamos y todo pero no me representa.
Y deberíamos considerar
que hay otros lugares en el mundo
que deberían interesarnos cuando contamos historias.
Hace que el mundo sea más pequeño.
No sé.
Creo que promueve la idea de que el mundo es un lugar universal,
y nuestras historias se vuelven universales.
Dejamos de ser otro.
CS: Tú innovaste, por lo que veo,
maneras interesantes de lanzar nuevos programas también.
Cuando lanzaste "Scandal" en 2012,
hubo una oleada de apoyo en Twitter
gustó como nunca antes.
¿Tienes otros ases bajo la manga
para cuando lances el próximo?
¿Qué crees que pasará al respecto?
SR: Sí tenemos unas ideas interesantes.
Lanzaremos en verano un programa llamado "Still Star-Crossed".
Tenemos algunas ideas interesantes.
No sé si podremos hacerlas a tiempo.
Me parecieron divertidas.
Pero la idea de transmitirlo en vivo
fue solo nuestra idea de que sería divertido.
No nos percatamos de que los críticos comenzarían a tuitear en vivo también.
Pero hacer que los seguidores fueran parte de ello
-- hacerlo como un campamento --
como cuando todos están en Twitter
y todos conversan juntos, es más bien una experiencia compartida
y encontrar otras formas de hacer eso posible
y encontrar otras formas de involucrar a las personas
es importante.
CS: Entonces, cuando todas esas personas hagan historias
y solo algunas logren
atraer a la audiencia de alguna forma
¿Cómo crees que se les pagará a los narradores?
SR: De hecho, he pensado en eso también.
¿Va a ser un modelo de suscripción?
¿La gente va a mirar el programa de una persona en particular,
y así lo haremos?
CS: Quizá deberíamos comprar un pasaporte a Shondalandia, ¿no?
SR: No lo sé, pero sí. Es mucho más trabajo para mí.
Creo en verdad que habrá diferentes maneras,
pero no necesariamente lo sé.
Para ser honesta hay muchos creadores de contenido
que no están necesariamente interesados en distribuir,
en gran parte porque lo que sueño hacer
es crear contenido.
Realmente me fascina crear contenido.
Que me paguen por ello
y que me paguen lo que merezco por ello
y es difícil encontrar eso.
Pero también quiero hacerlo posible
para la gente con quien trabajo, ¿sabes?,
los que trabajan para mí,
que a todos se les pague y puedan vivir de ello.
El cómo distribuirlo se vuelve más y más difícil.
CS: ¿Qué hay de las nuevas herramientas,
realidad virtual, realidad aumentada...
me fascina que no se pueda hacer maratón televisivo,
no se puede adelantar con esas herramientas.
¿Cuál crees que sea el futuro de estas tecnologías en la narración?
SR: Pasé mucho tiempo el año pasado
explorándolas,
tuve muchas demostraciones y les presté atención.
Me parecen fascinantes,
en gran parte porque creo que...
la mayoría de las personas piensan que son para jugar,
la mayoría piensa que son para cosas de acción,
y creo que hay un sentido de intimidad
muy presente en esas cosas,
la idea de que... imagina esto,
puedes estar sentada aquí y conversar con Fitz,
o al menos estar aquí mientras Fitz te habla,
el presidente Fitzgerald Grant III,
mientras él te cuenta
por qué tomó la decisión que tomó,
y es un momento conmovedor.
Y en lugar de mirar una pantalla de TV,
estás sentada junto a él, y él te está contando esto.
Y te enamoras de él
mientras lo hace... desde una pantalla de TV.
Imagínate sentada junto a él
o estar con un personaje como Huck quien está a punto de ejecutar a alguien.
Y en lugar de tener una escena
donde él le habla a otro personaje muy rápidamente,
vaya a un armario y gire hacia ti y te diga,
lo que va a pasar y por qué tiene miedo y está nervioso.
Es un poco más como el teatro y no estoy segura de que funcione,
pero me fascina el concepto
y lo que significaría para la audiencia.
Y poder jugar con esas ideas sería interesante.
¿Sabes? Creo que para mi audiencia, la gente que mira mis programas,
mujeres de 12 a 75 años,
hay algo interesante allí para ellas.
CS: ¿Qué hay de la opinión de la audiencia?
¿Qué tanto te interesan las cosas
donde la audiencia puede hasta cierto punto
decidir sus propias aventuras.
Si prefieren a Fitz o si prefieren a...
SR: Ah, historias donde uno elige sus aventuras.
Me han costado trabajo esas,
no necesariamente porque quiera tener control de todo,
sino porque cuando veo la TV o estoy viendo una película,
sé muy bien que una historia no es tan buena
cuando tengo el control sobre lo que quiero que le ocurra
al personaje de otra persona.
¿Sabes? Podría decirte exactamente lo quería que le ocurriera a Walter White,
y está bien, pero la historia no es la misma y no es tan poderosa.
Si estoy a cargo de cómo termina "Los Soprano",
entonces es encantador, tengo un final agradable y satisfactorio,
pero no es la misma historia y no tiene el mismo impacto emocional.
CS: No puedo dejar de imaginar cómo sería.
Lo siento, estoy yendo un poco lejos.
SR: Lo asombroso es que no logro imaginarlo,
porque Vince tiene su propio final,
y el que otra persona lo haya decidido lo hace realmente poderoso.
¿Sabes? Si uno decidiera eso,
en "Tiburón", el tiburón ganaría,
no tendría el mismo efecto.
Es la historia es la historia que se cuenta
y puedes enojarte o puedes dudar de ella
y puedes discutir,
pero así funciona.
Por eso es arte.
De otra manera, sería solo un juego,
y los juegos pueden ser arte, pero de manera muy diferente.
CS: Los videojugadores que venden el derecho de sentarse ahí
y comentar lo que ocurre
para mí es más una comunidad que una narración.
SR: Y esa es su propia manera de reunirse.
No descarto que sea una forma de narración
pero es un formato grupal, supongo.
CS: Muy bien, ¿qué hay del súper-súper...
el hecho de que todo sea más y más breve.
Ahora, Snapchat tiene programas
que duran un minuto.
SR: Es interesante.
Una parte de mí piensa que parecen comerciales.
Es decir, lo son, tienen patrocinador.
Pero una parte de mí lo comprende completamente.
Hay algo realmente asombroso en ello.
Si piensas que hay un mundo
en que la mayoría de las personas mira TV en sus teléfonos,
si piensas en lugares como India,
donde más se transmite
y donde más se mira, lo más breve tiene sentido.
Si se le puede cobrar a la gente más dinero por menos contenido,
el distribuidor ha encontrado una manera de hacer mucho más dinero.
Si uno crea contenido,
cuesta menos dinero hacerlo y publicarlo.
Y, por cierto,
alguien de 14 años y un corto periodo de atención, como mi hija,
quiere ver eso, quieres producir eso,
así funciona.
Y si lo haces bien y realmente parece una narración,
las personas se engancharán sin importar lo que uno haga.
CS: Me alegra que hayas criado a tus hijas,
porque me pregunto cómo consumirán ellas entretenimiento,
y no solo entretenimiento,
las noticias también.
Cuando los señores supremos algorítmicos
proveen lo mismo.
¿Cómo corregiremos eso para lograr ciudadanos plenos?
SR: Bueno, cómo lo corrijo yo
es algo completamente diferente de cómo lo haría otra persona.
CS: Siéntete libre de especular.
SR: No sé cómo lo haremos en el futuro, en realidad.
Mis hijas han pasado por todos mis experimentos.
Aún hacemos lo que llamo "veranos amish"
porque desconecto todo electrónico,
guardo sus computadoras y cosas
y las miro enloquecer un rato hasta resignarse
en un verano libre de electrónicos.
Pero honestamente es un mundo muy difícil
en el que ahora, como adultos,
solo nos interesa mirar lo propio,
y no sabemos que estamos cerrados
en nuestras opiniones nada más.
Hoy en día
miras una noticia,
y la fuente de noticias se corrige
para que solo veas tus propias ideas
y sientes cada vez que estás más en lo correcto.
¿Cómo puede uno discernir?
Es un tanto alarmante.
Así que quizá sobrecorrija, quizá todo explote,
o quizá solo nos volvamos...
detesto ser negativa al respecto,
quizá nos volvamos todos más tontos.
(Cindy ríe)
CS: Sí, ¿imaginas alguna corrección que puedas hacer
a una pieza guionada de ficción?
SR: Pienso mucho sobre que la TV puede educar a la gente de manera poderosa,
y si miras la TV...
por ejemplo, hacen estudios sobre programas médicos.
Creo que es un 87 % de la gente
que obtiene la mayor parte de su conocimiento sobre medicina
de los programas médicos,
mucho más de lo que obtienen de sus médicos
o de artículos.
Trabajamos arduamente para ser precisos, y cuando cometemos un error,
me siento muy culpable, como si hiciéramos algo malo,
pero también damos mucha buena información médica.
Hay otras maneras de dar información en esos programas.
Se está educando a la gente
y quizá no quieran leer las noticias,
pero hay muchas otras maneras de dar información justa en esos programas
no de una manera espeluznante como si controláramos el pensamiento,
pero de alguna manera es algo muy interesante e inteligente
sin hacer a un lado ninguna perspectiva,
o proclamando la verdad.
Sería extraño, no obstante,
si a través de las series dramáticas diéramos las noticias.
CS: Sería extraño,
pero entiendo que mucho de lo que has escrito como ficción
se ha vuelto una predicción esta temporada.
SR: ¿Sabes? "Scandal" ha sido muy perturbador por esa razón.
Tenemos este programa sobre la política que enloquece,
y básicamente la manera de contar...
ya sabes, todos prestamos atención a los papeles.
Leemos todo. Hablamos de todo.
Tenemos muchos amigos en Washington.
Y siempre hemos hecho el programa como una especulación.
Solemos sentarnos a pensar,
¿y si las llantas se desprendieran del autobús
y todo enloqueciera?
Siempre fue fantástico
excepto que ahora parece como si se hubieran desprendido
y todo ha enloquecido,
las cosas que especulamos se están volviendo verdad.
Nuestra temporada este año
iba a terminar con los rusos controlando las elecciones de EE.UU.
y lo habíamos escrito y planeado,
todo estaba allí,
y luego se sospechaba que los rusos estuvieron involucrados en las elecciones
y de repente tuvimos que cambiar lo que íbamos a hacer en la temporada.
Entré y me dije:
"Esa escena donde la mujer misteriosa empieza a hablar ruso,
tenemos que cambiarla y pensar qué vamos a hacer".
Eso resulta de extrapolar
lo que pensamos que iba a pasar,
o lo que creímos alocado.
CS: Qué genial.
¿En qué otra parte del mundo buscas, aparte de EE.UU.?
¿Quién está haciendo narraciones interesantes ahora?
SR: No lo sé, hay muchas cosas interesantes por ahí.
Obviamente la TV británica siempre es sorprendente
y siempre hace cosas interesantes.
No veo mucha TV,
en gran parte porque estoy ocupada trabajando.
Y trato de no ver mucha TV,
incluso TV de EE.UU. hasta que termino la temporada,
porque sino se me meten ideas en la cabeza.
Me empiezo a preguntar cosas como
"¿por qué nuestros personajes no usan coronas y hablan de tronos?"
Enloquezco.
Así que trato casi de no ver hasta que termina la temporada.
Pero sí creo que hay TV europea muy interesante.
Estuve en los Emmys internacionales
y vi varias cosas que estaban transmitiendo,
y me fascinó.
Hay algunas cosas que quisiera ver y revisar.
CS: ¿Te imaginas...
sé que no piensas mucho tiempo en cosas tecnológicas,
pero sabes que hace unos años alguien vino aquí a TED
a hablar sobre el ver,
portaba lentes de Google y podía ver los programas en los ojos?
¿Tienes fantasías sobre...
la niña sentada en el piso
en la casa de tus padres,
has imaginado algún otro medio?
¿O lo harías ahora?
SR: ¿Otro medio,
para narrar, aparte de los libros?
Crecí queriendo ser Toni Morrison, así que no.
Ni siquiera imaginé la televisión.
La idea de que puede haber un mundo más grande,
una manera mágica de hacer cosas...
siempre me emociono con lo nuevo de la tecnología
y siempre soy la primera en querer probarlo.
Las posibilidades son infinitas y emocionantes ahora,
y eso me emociona.
Estamos en esta especie de Lejano Oeste y siento...
que nadie sabe cómo terminará todo.
Hoy puedes hacer historias acerca de todo
y eso me gusta,
y parece como si, una vez que averigüemos cómo juntar la tecnología
y la creatividad,
las posibilidades serán infinitas.
CS: Y la tecnología también ha permitido lo que sugerí hace un momento,
atracones televisivos, un fenómeno reciente,
desde que empezaste a hacer programas ¿no?
¿Cómo crees que eso cambia el proceso narrativo?
Siempre tuviste una biblia durante toda la temporada, ¿no?
SR: No, simplemente siempre supe cómo iba a terminar.
Así que para mí,
lo único que puedo comentar al respecto
es que tengo un programa que ha existido por 14 temporadas
y hay gente que lo ha estado mirando durante las 14 temporadas,
y hay chicas de 12 años que he encontrado en el supermercado
que han mirado 297 episodios en tres semanas.
En serio, y esa es una experiencia muy distinta para ellas,
porque han estado dentro de algo
muy intensamente durante un periodo muy corto de tiempo
de manera muy intensa,
y para ellas la historia tiene un arco completamente diferente
y un significado muy distinto
porque nunca se ha interrumpido.
CS: Es como visitar un país para luego marcharse. Es extraño...
SR: Es como leer una novela estupenda y después dejarla.
Creo que esa es la belleza de esta experiencia.
No necesitas mirar algo durante 14 temporadas.
No tiene que ser necesariamente de esa manera.
CS: ¿Hay algún tema que creas que no debamos tocar?
SR: No veo la narración de esa manera.
Pienso en la historia en términos de personajes y lo que harían
y lo que necesitan hacer los personajes para desarrollarse,
así que nunca pienso en la historia solo en términos de su trama,
cuando los escritores vienen a mi oficina y me lanzan su trama
les digo, "No estás hablando de verdad".
Les digo eso.
No estamos hablando de verdad. Necesito escuchar lo real.
Así que no lo pienso así.
No sé si existe una forma de pensar que haya algo que no haría
porque sería como arrancar piezas de la trama de un muro.
CS: Es genial. ¿Hasta qué punto crees que usarás...
recientemente estuviste en el panel de "Planned Parenthood"
y te involucraste con la campaña de Hillary Clinton.
¿Hasta qué punto crees que usarás la narración
en el mundo real
para ejercer un cambio?
SR: Bueno, sabes, hay...
Es un tema intenso para mí,
porque siento que la escasez de narración
en mucha gente es difícil.
¿Sabes? Es como si hubiera muchas organizaciones
que no tienen una narración positiva porque no la han creado para sí,
para ayudarse.
Hay muchas campañas
a las que les iría bien con una mejor narración.
Los demócratas podrían hacer mucho
con una narración fuerte para sí.
Podrían ocurrir muchas cosas diferentes
al usar la voz de la narración,
y no me refiero a hacerlo en forma de ficción,
sino en la misma manera en que lo haría un escritor de discursos.
Y veo eso,
pero no sé si necesariamente ese sería mi trabajo.
CS: Muy bien.
Por favor, démosle las gracias a Shonda. SR: Gracias.
(Aplausos)